Welcome to this presentation
of Google Play Services 6.1.
In this video, we will look
at all the new features
we've added and that you can
use to build better apps.
That's right.
That's what Google Play
Services is all about,
building better apps.
To give you some perspective,
take this chair for example.
This chair on Google
Play has given me
a completely new perspective
of what a chair can be like.
And it's exactly the same thing
with Google Play Services.
When you look at
all of the APIs,
such as Games, Location Context,
Maps, Drive, Wallet, Ads,
and all the new APIs
we add all the time,
it will give you new perspective
of Google Play Services.
But for now, let's check
out Google Play Services
6.1 and all the new
features we've added.
So starting off with the
Google Drive Android API.
This release includes
Completion Events,
which allows your app to
get notified when actions
are committed to the server.
And this also makes it possible
to respond to conflict, in case
there are parallel updates.
And DriveResource now has
the method Set Parent,
and although it doesn't
sound like much,
this is quite a
big deal since it
allows you to programmatically
organize files and folders.
And finally, there is a class
called Drive Content that
simplifies working with
file, that's right, content.
So if you haven't already,
let's stop and think
about this for a second.
Google Drive is like a
hard drive in the cloud,
always available and
accessible from any device.
With this in mind, wouldn't
you be building a better app
if you used Google Drive?
Hmm?
Oh yeah!
Of course, you would.
Moving on to Google Tag Manager.
Hopefully you're
already a devoted user
of Google Analytics
Enhanced Ecommerce, which
allows you to get analytics
data on an activity flow,
for example, a purchasing flow.
That's right.
Data is the key word
here, and as you know,
you can have a lot
of fun with data.
You can, for example, slice
it, dice it, and massage it.
But apart from just
doing those operations,
data is actually
very useful since it
can represent things
happening in our world.
Take a shopping
site for example,
where it's pretty
important to know
what makes it easy
and compelling
for customers to buy things.
Well Enhanced Ecommerce can
provide you with all this data.
Let's look at this example.
In the first step
here, you can see
that there were almost
19,500 recorded sessions,
but almost 14,000
of those did not
result in any shopping activity.
But there were almost 5,500
product specification views,
but 4,700 of those
did not result
in shopping cart activity.
But there were 560 checkouts,
But 500 of those were canceled.
So you can see out
of those 19,500
or so sessions we started
off with, only 64 became
actual shopping transactions.
And this is the power
of Enhanced Ecommerce.
It will give you the end
to end view of what works
and what doesn't work, so you
can improve and become better.
And in this release, we're happy
to announce that the Google Tag
Manager also supports Enhanced
Ecommerce through the Universal
Analytics Tag.
So make sure to check Enhanced
Ecommerce and Google Tag
Manager out because what
you don't know about,
you can't improve.
That's why data is so great.
That's it for this release
of Google Play Services,
but remember to check out
all the APIs of Google Play
Services, because there's
so much stuff in there
that you can use to
create better apps.
And check out these
resources as well.
Now it's your turn to go out
there and build better apps,
and don't forget to
tell us all about it.